i want to do a little bit of an update
on a story there is a news story here
but it there also isn't in the sense
that we already had the facts
about the real coveted mortality and
fatality rate in the state of new york
there are a bunch of different headlines
now which say things like
new york governor acknowledges nearly 12
000 more covet fatality fatalities than
publicized by andrew cuomo
and the story goes
new york governor kathy hoechel promised
more government transparency on her
first day in office and by day's end her
administration had quietly delivered it
by acknowledging nearly 12 000 more
deaths in the state from covid19 than
had been publicized by her predecessor
andrew cuomo new york now reports nearly
55 400
um based on death certificate
see up from 43
400 that cuomo had reported to the
public as of monday his last name in
office we are now releasing more data
than had been released before publicly
so people know the nursing home deaths
and hospital deaths are consistent with
what's being displayed by the cdc got a
bunch of emails from people saying david
i don't understand
i looked on you know world domiters and
the cdc website nothing changed and
that's exactly right the scandal here
was
that the uh cuomo administration
was not acknowledging roughly these 10
to 12 what was 10 now is known to be 12
000 cova deaths
but the cdc was always acknowledging
them and websites like worldometers and
others are based on cdc data so
this is more of a political story than
it is a whoa there's actually 12 000
more people that died we knew about that
and we reported it um feels like it's
been a couple of months since we we
learned of that
now when it comes to andrew cuomo
what is even worse the covet stuff or
the sexual harassment stuff i think at
the macro level not to diminish what
andrew cuomo has been credibly accused
of based on a report i think that the
covet stuff without a doubt has been
worse
but this is not actually new information
it's just that it's now being
acknowledged formally by the state uh
good to see the new governor acknowledge
it at the same time
uh
there's an aspect of this that seems
very political in the sense that the
data was already out there we covered it
months ago this sort of is like a get
out of jail free card for everybody else
in the executive branch and it's
probably legitimate to say really this
is andrew cuomo
they threw cuomo out cuomo gets the
blame and now kathy hoechel or is it
hokel actually don't know how it's
pronounced um acknowledges it and it's
sort of like hey everything's good now
well the truth is it's very hard to
imagine
that more people within
the um administration of the state
government of new york didn't know that
this was going on so there's an aspect
of this that feels like this is the
perfect timing to just acknowledge it
and move on and try to avoid any other
consequences for anybody now that
cuomo's gone and the numbers match the
cdc
but in some sense it's good that they
have now said yes this is the real
number of deaths here in the state of
new york if you think that this has any
importance beyond just quietly putting
it out there so that now they can move
on and try to prevent anybody else
from having any kind of consequence as a
result
let me know but the data's not new and
it seems to me like a pretty brazen act
of
say it sweep it under the rug and then
if it ever comes up again say that was
on cuomo and cuomo is now gone we've
taken care of the problem everybody's
gotten the consequence they deserve
let me know we'll be covering this more
on our instagram where you can find us
at david pakman show find me on
instagram as well at david david.pacman